nous sommes en juillet dans le port du
vivier-sur-mer tous les producteurs de
moules sont sur les dents pour
l'ouverture de la saison estivale
dans l'entreprise familiale
eric retrouve son frère marc avec ils
vont se répartir les rôles
tenus à la montre bien vrai que nos
maigres au chronomètre qui se déclenche
on part trois heures avant la basse perd
on revient deux heures après donc on a
on a vraiment une amplitude de travail
qui est limité
[Musique]
à
dans cette partie de la baie du mont
saint michel
les jours de grandes marées des engins
uniques en leur genre prennent la route
des bateaux qui roule ou si vous voulez
des camions qui flotte c'est selon ça
dépend de l'heure de l'heure de la marée
bien sûr c'est un agent en civil ils ont
été inventés en 77 nous aurons 18 en
fait pour la mytiliculture en baie du
mont saint michel la taille de l'estran
nous oblige finalement avoir des engins
très adapté au terrain mais finalement
c'est ça on part du port en roulant
on va jusqu'à jusqu'à l'eau et lorsqu'on
arrive sur l'eau ça vient finalement
vraiment un bateau et on peut naviguer
jusqu'à nous concessions à partir de ce
moment aujourd'hui on va mettre
une heure à peu près on naviguera une
heure pour atteindre ont cessé
la première recette des producteurs de
moules de la région la voilà c'est cet
engin il faut dire qu'ils n'ont pas le
choix leurs champs de production sont à
une dizaine de kilomètres au large
tantôt à sec tantôt immergé d'où ce
drôle d'engin sorte de couteau suisse
maritime locale
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres à vol d'oiseau des
producteurs de moules le port de
granville
un autre bateau un vrai sens rouge celui
là s'apprête à partir pour une autre
course contre la montre pour la pêche à
la palourde
aurait mis pour y aller une heure et
demie pour revenir donc on est parti
pour huit heures à partir de maintenant
à fond à fond ouais ben alaoui
[Musique]
comme henrique marques et yann
britannique d'origine et son équipage
honteux pas une minute à perdre là où
ils vont c'est parfois tout ou rien
[Musique]
il part profité de la marée de vin champ
d'îles perdu au large de granville
l'archipel de chausey
ici tel un grand pour la mer respire var
vient
seuls les jours de grandes marées
permettent d'accéder à ces espaces
habituellement immergé
dans quelques heures à mesure que la
marée va descendre de plus en plus de
salles va se découvrir autant de plages
riche en coquillages
à bord du navire de yann chacun sait
exactement ce qu'il va avoir à faire ici
aussi une stricte répartition des rôles
jean ping matin je suis pas encore le
coup de feu l'a juste derrière les
lesbiennes sont sous l'eau lancé à
l'époque
on va se mettre au mouillage la
justice'' car on a travaillé qu'avec les
barges qui sont le bateau va rester là
ils savent que transpole transports
sur place les marins ont laissé d'autres
bateaux plus adaptés et des barges qui
permettent de se faufiler dans quelques
centimètres d'eau au ras des cailloux
cinq minute perdue c'est
peut être la différence entre
réussir à tout faire ou pas cinq minutes
ça peut être la différence de la barge
chou on peut parvenir
parfois ça joue à très peu
une partie de l'équipage s'éloigne de
son côté vers les parcs à huîtres il ya
des séries préparent leur cagnotte pour
pouvoir s'approcher des plages à
coquillages
sur les îles les plus hautes déjà
d'autres récoltant
il ya un et cyril les rejoindre et
s'élève maintenant à pied sac
les palourdes y ait de chausey ils sont
tous en quelque sorte des jardiniers de
la mer quelques jours par mois ils
viennent ici ramasser ce qu'ils ont semé
mêlant
l'anr et vient jamais
sur le point culminant de l'archipel une
dizaine de mètres au dessus du niveau de
la mer ils vont récupérer des engins
qu'on ne s'attendait pas à voir au
milieu d'un tel paysage normalement
aujourd'hui je dois récolté 900 kilos de
khat
et parce que 500 kg de palourdes à la
main
ça prend un temps fou ça
encore une demi heure et les chants de
palourdes seront tous à découvert
au moule on retrouve eric qui a rejoint
les premiers parcs pour lui c'est déjà
parti
là c'est le moment de l'ensemencement
accroché ses cordes ses filets tout en
longueur qui contiennent des centaines
de baies des moules
la mère a maintenant déjà suffisamment
baissé les pieux apparaissent c'est le
signal la première phase du travail là
aussi il faut être pile poil à l'heure
là leur part baissé pour la besoin
d'aller très vite
il y à peu ses bouchons étaient encore
inaccessibles
donc une fausse du filet sur les trains
le but étant de nous protéger des
tempêtes effectivement donc les les
vagues qui déferlent en lecture peuvent
décrocher les moulins et ce filet et les
filets qui vont suivre d'ailleurs parce
qu'on en pousse successivement environ
quatre ou cinq par an il ya
effectivement de rempart contre les
tempêtes
[Musique]
donc là on voit qu'elle a le niveau de
la mer des sons au fur et à mesure
d'ailleurs d'ici d'ici une demi-heure on
pourra plus parce qu'elle est ou serait
beaucoup trop
nulle part ailleurs un phénomène naturel
donne à ce point le tempo du travail à
faire
et là il reste qu permettre à mes coups
d'ailleurs on va être belle fera sec
on va devoir défendre
au même moment à 5 kilomètres la uno est
encore haute dans son engin amphibie
mark le frère s'apprête à récolter
des moules traite à la consommation
moins d'une heure il s'agit de récolter
quelques tonnes de moules
[Musique]
alors ça c'est les pieux ça fait presque
un an qu'on travaille dessus finalement
on les a protégés les prédateurs on nous
a protégés des tempêtes avec différents
filet
et aujourd'hui c'est l'aboutissement
basse c'est une belle journée pour nous
[Musique]
pendant que marc récolte non-stop pieux
par pieux
bush par bush ou
au nord de la baie les plages de chausey
sont enfin découverte il ya un et cyril
ont enfourché leurs tracteurs ils vont
pouvoir enfin travailler
[Applaudissements]
là c'est trop mou
à l'égout
ne pas laisser mes gars là non ces
places sont éphémères elles
n'apparaissent que quelques jours par
mois seul liane cyril et les autres
producteurs de palourdes les connaissent
sur le bout des doigts
avec leur récolteuse les deux compères
commencent par les coqs ils ont semé
maintenant ils cueillent comme un
travail agricole
sur le domaine maritime
les jours de grandes marées josé est
prisé des plaisanciers comme des
pêcheurs à pied qui n'ont bien sûr pas
le droit de récolter ce que les
professionnels on se met mais c'est vrai
que c'est tentant
que l'argumentation ces trois mètres à
l'extérieur des parcs l'ensemble ces
parades et piqué
cc3 m
merci bonne journée
rappel à l'ordre de yann qui n'a pas que
ça à faire lui un objectif remplir ses
cagettes dare-dare du temps de marée
basse permis c'est autant d'argent perdu
6 ans qu'il a failli attendre sur la
machine
[Musique]
sur cette autre plage ces bandes de
tissus prothèses des prédateurs crabe ou
oiseaux les naissains de palourdes de
tout petits coquillages qui atteindront
la taille adulte en 300
ont trouvé par mètre carré
que nous on s'aime
220 m²
petite
perte naturelle bien la prédation
on vivait à la moitié
ça c'est la première récolte de trois
ans d'investissement dans le sable
le parc de moules a encore changé de
visage et voilà eric plus tranquille
le tempo s'est ralenti nous sommes
maintenant à l'état de basse mer le
moment de la bascule
eric et son équipage sont dans 20 cm
d'eau à pied au milieu des bouchons avec
plus que quelques cordes à fixer
alors les boules de l'année
si elle pas de grandes marées ici on
pourrait pas à planter nos bouchons
c'est à dire qu'on a besoin d espace
pour s'implanter et faut savoir qu'on
n'est pas dans la production à outrance
c'est une production raisonnée
l'implantation des bouchoux en fête a
été gelé il ya maintenant de très
nombreuses années
et on est sur une production très très
stable d'environ 10000 tonnes par an
depuis maintenant deux cuisses années 80
soit 110 80 dire
c'est parce que la mère brasse disparaît
réapparaît à air ou noix que les
coquillages sont si particulier dans la
baie du mont saint michel
et il en va de même dans l'archipel de
chausey
ici
la course n'est pas encore terminée
pas question pour yann de charger les
barges trop tard pas question de laisser
remonter la mer sans s'occuper des
tracteurs
tu poses
à
5 heures
on a les pieds dans l'eau ici 18 heures
en
on est sous l'eau c'est sûr donc dans
deux heures
et normalement on en deux heures on est
presque à granville
il est 18h dans l'archipel de chausey
les plages ont disparu
impossible d'y récolter maintenant quoi
que ce soit c'est fini
il ya mené ces équipes se retrouvent
autour du grand bateau qui va les
ramener sur le continent à granville
faut laisser sur la barge ouais mais ça
m'évite de procès le lendemain
8,1 au total de produits récoltés dans
la journée bilan mitigé bouriane on
aurait pu faire mieux aujourd'hui la
mère elle est descendue assez vite donc
les gars n'avaient pas le temps de tout
faire avant que la barge arriver son
sable
demain il faudra encore revenir pour une
autre course contre la montre
infatigable pêcheurs de moules
inépuisable ramasseurs de palourdes
[Musique]